faire l'interview kevin r
salut cavina ça ne dérange pas si je te
tutoie kevin ah non ça donne quasiment
l'âge de mon grand père kevin on sait
qu'à une grosse poitrine pour ton âge ah
ouais tu trouves ça oui c'est un
soixante eh bien il se fait que l'âge
maintenant balin disons dans quatre ans
je rêve un an ouais raison qu'aucune
classe un chien scène deux parce que j
redoublé trois fois c'est de ces mêmes
parents considèrent que je suis trop
mûrs et écoute quoi comme musique ans je
manquais viennent à un badigeon je
télécharge tout sur internet alors je
sais pas trop
dis-moi kevin hart est allé voir mélanie
concert avec justin timberlake à paris
j'ai une copine qui était alors gistré
tout le concert
son téléphone parce qu'elle a un sens et
néo tu veux faire quoi plus tard kevin
na où je suis pas j'aimerais bien être
une star
magali qui s'intéressent à la politique
et li na waie jeudi dont je pense que
l'année prochaine je veux très pur pour
nicolas royal et ségolène ségolène
sarkozy sait pas si longtemps bien que
tu es vieux ouais je me sens bien je
n'entends gaz et que ma mère mais mon
beau-père un connard elie semoun tu
aimes bien glissé - ah ouais j'aime bien
j'aime bien son amour j'aime bien disons
pour moi c'est le meilleur comique de
ces générations
et franck dubosc ou un blason du vol ait
robots y ressemble à alain delon mais en
plus vieux et tu crois le sens et
lentilles bleues ils auraient fait la
même carrière font du buzz
non je ne crois pas ouais c'est toujours
avec kad a changé de mains eric icade
icad un homme a été amené jean et on
jules pour la saint-valentin kevina
haoues on a été dans ses restaurants
américains au mcdo vous embrasser sur la
bouche avec ton mec ou non non c'est
juste des snacks a mais pas la langue
un nom juste avec mon chien vous avez
jamais couché ensemble en fait non je
couche qu'avec les peluches pour
l'instant et c'est a fait quoi
d'apprendre que britney spears était
maman kevin ah oui qu'est ce tu fais
après l'émission kevin ah ben je rentre
chez moi je pourquoi tu as quelque chose
à me proposer la soirée au baron ah
ouais super j'adore la grande
bourgeoisie